hey I want to welcome you to our
funfilled
afternoon discussing Islamic law in
America how the Obama administration
department of justice is selling out the
American people it's interesting to me
that this is the only event at CPAC
addressing this crucial issue uh the
fact that they are not addressing it we
are independent afdi and S are putting
this event on as you can see with great
difficulty I see the sweating faces the
panting and the pushing and the shoving
the standing room only which tells you
the Keen interest there is in this
issue not only did American law for
American courts the foreign law
prohibition pass in three states and
Robert Muse will discuss that in detail
but it's being proposed in 25 other
states people care about this now the
people will say but there's no such
thing in is as Islamic law in America
there's no Sharia in America we're
protected by the first am
and I am telling you that it is creeping
the mosing of the workplace imposing
Muslim prayer times on Union contracts
uh the hindes company who is enormously
generous to their Muslim workers they
have prayer rugs they have prayer rooms
is now being sued to stop the line stop
the line for Muslim prayer times now
they don't do this in Muslim countries
that live under the Sharia they pray
before they pray afterwards so why do it
here because it is a way of imposing
Islam on the secular Marketplace
and many Muslims that come to this
country come here to escape the Sharia
not to bring the Sharia and it's
interesting to me that the voices that
we hear are all Islamic supremacist
voices and this is not a partisan issue
because this morning you had suel Khan
completely
whitewashing uh Sharia giving out these
leave behind why Jews can't criticize
Sharia law what do the Jews have to do
with this first of of all there's no
compulsion in Jewish law there is no
compulsion in canon law it's
voluntary the Sharia is a comprehensive
political system governing every aspect
of human life that asserts authority
over non-muslims do you understand what
I'm saying so this is why you see in in
Muslim countries living under the Sharia
the oppression subjugation persecution
and Slaughter of Christians in Egypt
it's happening in Thailand in Indonesia
so what I want to do here is show you
how speech is uh being silenced and
being censored uh suel Khan giving this
away to the uninitiated and when someone
queried him and said you know read
Robert Spencer's books scholar on Islam
10 books sual Khan whose best bud is
Alam Moody serving a life sentence with
being an alaa fin the number one alaa
financer in America but he was a
moderate Muslim voice in the 9s before
he went to jail said Robert Spencer
doesn't know what he's talking about
that's why Robert Spencer is not asked
to speak and Robert Spencer is not
included in our inclusion panels no no
that was the name of the panel inclusion
conservative inclusion so uh the masking
of the workplace the masking of the
schools the you know introducing these
whitewashed Islamic curriculums taking
the children to mosque uh Sharia Finance
where your taxpayer dollars are being
used to fund Sharia Finance now you can
say well what's wrong with that a Sharia
Finance has to be halow and what does
that mean it means they cannot invest in
pork in alcohol in tobacco and some
forms of entertainment those are whole
American sectors you want your taxpayer
dollars going to starve and bankrupt
whole American sectors and 2.5% of it
has to go to
zat which we know funds Jihad so we have
to talk about
this I've assembled for you a stellar if
I may say so
myself a stellar panel who can address
this from all different points on the
prism my first speaker is arario Pantano
[Applause]
Ario is a war hero he's running for
congress in North Carolina he has been
in the belly of the Beast and he has
courage he has political will when they
come after him for having anything to do
with me he does not pretend he doesn't
know me which people do and by the way I
understand because the attacks on me the
liist
defamation destroying my reputation
withering attacks scam people doesn't
scam me bring it on I'm as clean as a
[Applause]
whistle you have to do the work for
Freedom you have to do the work freedom
is not free and you cannot assume your
freedom and you cannot live on the F
fumes of World War II and the America of
the 20th century you have to fight this
war this war is here I I want to I want
to get everybody in it's very important
so we're going to sweat I think they I
think Rover North put the heat
onio p
that was actually me I requested they
turn the heat up so you all would know
what it feels like in
Iraq we're going to come back tomorrow
when it's about 120 degrees is that okay
friends it's a it's a real honor to be
with so many of you and I can say
friends um a lot of you have been in
this fight for some time now and I think
that in 2010 after a lot of hard work
for a couple of years a lot of us could
agree that we got some hope and in 2012
God willing we're going to get the
chance so continue to work continue to
activate I am going to talk to you a
little bit today about some of the
foundational underpinning of this
argument the conversation about Sharia
and its viability in the United States
Visa the US Constitution the
underpinnings and the foundings of this
nation where we come from who we are as
a people and how we reconcile these
different belief systems going into the
21st century that's going to be
something that's going to be a high
button for a long time before I get into
too much detail and into the weeds
because frankly we have speakers that
are much more capable than I in giving
you the descriptions and the statistics
and the correct
pronunciations I do want to take a
little bit of time to tell you how it is
that I got here Pamela incorrectly
addressed me as a war hero I'm not that
but I have been a soldier in a couple of
Wars because I do think that this
country is worth fighting for and if
need be it's worth dying for and I don't
say that lightly I'm very young and I
have every every weight that you can
imagine of the cost and the consequence
of that I want to tell you a little bit
about the things that I believe our sons
and daughters fight for and why they do
it and I want to talk to you a little
bit about my experience because when
Pamela talks about the concern of
reprisal the concern of demonization by
a media intend to destroy not only
conservative values but conservative
opinions conservative voices and conserv
of stals I have a little bit of
experience with that had any of you
heard of me before I ran for
congress some of you had right the
Marine with a good haircut back there
that's cuz we're so close to quanico
friends I was charged with murder for
killing terrorists in Iraq and I give
you that story because I know firsthand
a little bit about what political
correctness run them up does I know what
it does to impede our capabilities I
know what it does to hurt our war
Fighters some of you might be familiar
with the story that's been out recently
in the media with Marines being
demonized for an unfortunate incident
when the reality is that dozens of
innocent men women and children and let
me focus on children as the father of a
seven and nyear old are being blown to
Pieces every single day but the outrage
has been focused on an anomaly instead
of focusing it where it belongs on an
Institutional practice of jihad so we
need to focus on the meat and not on the
peace so I'm going to be a little bit of
the warmup for the conversation and and
Robert's laughing at me because Robert
remembers when we met a couple of years
ago and we were sitting at a table and
and my wife and I were there and I said
well what are you doing he said well I'm
in the anti- Jihad business and of
course you know he runs Jihad watch and
and and that's a wonderful resource and
website and I hope if you didn't know
that I hope you go through it if you're
watching on the we I hope you
go and and my wife kind of looked at me
and you know my Marine Corp pin I said
well I'm in the anti- Jihad business too
I'm just in the business end of the
anti- Jihad business you know
and friends I'll tell you that that my
my walk and I come to you today not as
an expert in political Islam not as an
expert in our founding I come to you
today as a witness and I need to qualify
this by saying I'm a Christian that was
born again in Christ and I give you that
qualifier because I clearly bring with
me a value set and a belief system that
is specific but I also want to give you
that because I share I believe a number
of the ideas and I carry an ideology
that was also represented at the time of
our founding and I want to talk a little
bit openly and honestly about that how
that's informed who we are today and how
that's going informed where we
go God works in mysterious ways just
before literally just before I walked in
here I received a phone call from a dear
friend of mine a general named Jack
singlo so may that name might be
familiar to some of you
he had a run in with uh the precursor to
President Obama a man named Jimmy Carter
and he was fired in 1977 by President
Jimmy Carter because he told the
president if you move troops out of
Korea you're going to bring us to a war
on the peninsula and it'd be a foolish
thing to do and the president called him
to the White House and said you better
not talk about this publicly again and
the next day the general was out there
decrying the foolishness of a naive
commander-in-chief the same man who by
the way 2 years later would be shocked
when the Soviets invade Afghanistan when
our American Embassy in Pakistan would
be bombed or when we would have
Americans taken hostage in Iran which
would precipitate of course not the
Iranian hostage crisis because they
weren't Iranians but the Americans taken
hostage in Iran crisis that we know so
well and that comes from inep and from
weak leadership I give you that because
when the phone rang frankly I was
concerned the general listen he jumped
into France in 1944 with the OSS he's
been around a while I was concerned when
the phone rang and I was glad to hear
his voice when he picked up and I said
sir I'm actually carrying a book that
you gave me that was written in 1989 and
that is as relevant today as when we
were talking a couple of years ago and
it's the book about legal terrorism do
you remember it and he said arario I do
and I said well sir can you share with
me some thoughts about what the justice
department is doing today and how that
their similarities to experiences that
you had in the 80s when you and other
members of various covert activities and
various intelligence gathering
activities would face not just scrutiny
but outright prosecution from the ACLU
but more importantly from private
organizations
funded with suspicious sources of money
making a deliberate effort to attack
conservatives conservative operatives
and their efforts in a term that in 1989
was coined legal terrorism this might
not be the origin of the term we'll have
some speaking to this in a bit but the
general and I first became acquainted
back in 2009 and this story matters as
well as we come full circle and talk a
little bit about this justice department
you see the general and I became
acquainted when Barack Obama in a
determination to plate a liberal base
Unleashed his Attorney General Eric
Holder on officer of the Central
Intelligence Agency and thus began the
process of investigation with a goal of
prosecution of our Intelligence Officers
back in 2009 does everyone remember that
seven directors of Central Intelligence
wrote a letter to the president saying
sir don't do this it's a mistake it's a
disaster our enemies won't trust us
pardon me our enemies they're looking
for the opportunity our friends won't
trust us and in this Administration
sometimes that's synonymous our friends
won't trust us our enemies will be
emboldened and our officers will be
weakened and
yet the letter went in the G file the
prosecution continued I got involved I
was at the time working on a master's
degree in national security policy I was
studying with some men and some women
who have been involved in the Reagan
Administration that were part of the
Cold War fight and general singl was one
of those figures I reached out to the
general I asked for some of his
assistance we reached out to some other
folks to get involved one man was a man
named Johnny span father of Mike span
the first American killed in Afghanistan
in the war on terror on November 25th
2001 Mike span got involved other
retired Intelligence Officers got
involved why because they needed someone
to advocate for them in a 247 media
environment that is
predominantly i w even say dominated
shaded colored painted by the left with
an agenda that very clearly is trying to
undermine the arguments of the right
thank you for joining us by the way this
is oury our key speaker he's got a lot
to say he's going to talk directly about
the justice department here in a little
bit we started this effort this
Grassroots effort called Stand with
intelligence in an effort to bring
attention to what the justice department
was doing and to speak for folks that
could not speak for themselves
specifically Intelligence Officers later
you would recall attorney general holder
wanting to bring bring khed shik
Muhammad to federal prison to try him in
federal court in New York City does
everyone remember the protest in
December maybe I met some of you all in
the rain that day in December in 2009
friends I'm giving you that story
because I'm not standing here as a
political opportunist that sees a hot
issue and says let me jump on that
because frankly these days it's more of
a political grenade and when you jump on
it people are afraid of of being
emulated well I'm not I'm not I come at
you as somebody was an activist before
he ever sought to be a representative
and somebody that regardless of the
consequences or of the success of a
political run will continue to be an
activist because I fight for the things
that I believe in and I'm hoping I'm
hoping
hoping I'm hoping that I can exort all
of you to join that fight in some way
and of course if you're here you
probably already are but I'm going to
give you some reference materials and
I'm doing the best I can to hold them
from slipping so I might start moving
I might even take a little bit of the
real estate right here well I mentioned
to you this book legal terrorism this is
a book that General sing wab gave to me
and I gave you that long way around so
that you understand I don't arrive at
this conversation as somebody that
looked at it quickly I've kind of been
in the trenches of this for a bit
General singlo experienced something in
the 80s which is very much alive and
well today we'll have a conversation
about that but when we look at books
today lawfare the war against Free
Speech it's ironic to think that one of
my friends somebody who probably is
imminently more qualified to be speaking
to all of these issues than I is not
even allowed or invited to speak here
today I salute you for calling out
connections for pointing out the
networks and frankly I also recognize
that in doing this at CAC I do it my
Peril but we've heard a president say
this before and I'm not afraid to say it
myself Bring it on Bring it on
so speaking of rich and we're going to
get into a little bit of the doctrine
and what it means to be a believer and
how that's compatible and what happens
when Sharia is really a political system
Beyond even just aota for religious
system but if one were to go into a book
store today and I did it I was up here
in DC and of course I live in
Southeastern North Carolina I do that by
choice the values are great the barbecue
is great it's where I raise my children
I see again a marine smiling you make me
happy do I have to slow down
though I've been a marine twice I can
say
that
friends I went to the bookstore with a
curiosity how would Islam and
specifically how would the threat from
radicals and from Jihad be presented
here we are in the nation's capital I
wanted to see what was available to
students we've got wonderful graduate
schools we've got wonderful
undergraduate schools and I was
surprised I went to a bookstore up on
Connecticut Avenue and the
most
forceful presentation of The Facts of
Islam
specifically the radicalization and the
encroachment of sharia and Jihad in the
United States was in fact an apologist
book called islamophobia The Challenge
of pluralism in the 21st century and I
mention this because I went looking for
something to speak to the threat and
what I found was basically a mirror with
a sticky finger saying you're the threat
buddy because you're islamophobic well
wait a second friends I had to take a
step back see because I'm not
and I know a lot of people in this room
feel the same way but friends I fought
two Wars to liberate Muslims from other
Muslims so don't tell me I'm is
homophobic and don't tell me that I'm a
racist please I'm just a student of
history and I want to understand
something you see when I pick up the
back of this and I see the books written
by John Esposito who's a professor of
religion and international Affairs at
Georgetown University and the founding
director of drum
roll the prince a in tal Center for
Muslim and Christian understanding I
said oh okay well that's an interesting
credential and then I noticed that the
next gentleman is also a fellow at the
prince Al bin tal Center for Muslim and
Christian understanding and then it kind
of resonates to me that wait a second
isn't that the same Prince that tried to
give $10 million back in right after 911
when the ruins were still smoldering and
I guess I ought to mention that Pamela
and I have become such good friends
because I've had the opportunity to
speak in a couple of events with her as
she's gone out to Champion the fact that
of course building a MOS Ground Zero is
a desecration of an American holy site
and an American
[Applause]
National but it struck me that that was
the same shake that had tried to give
Rudy Giuliani $10 million of course with
the strings attached that really I mean
mayor I mean this you have to kind of
admit it's Israel's fault right and of
course the mayor said no it's not keep
your money but that's a little bit of
the mindset well wait a second just this
is more complicated because that same
sheep is given $20 million to the very
graduate program of which these men as
fellows are ultimately probably
collecting a check but more to the point
and I don't want to impune their
individual Integrity because I don't
know them what I do want to do is
mention the this $20 million buys a lot
of interns and a lot of research time so
in essence what's being sold in a
private bookstore available to the mass
Market is propaganda that's coming out
of Saudi Arabia and this is what
represented Islam well as a Christian I
wanted to
see what did they have there just out of
curiosity I mean we're in Washington DC
this is the crossroads of the world the
nation's
capital and I was struck by what I found
so again I wanted to see if they had
anything on Sharia the threat of the
imposition of it and what that means to
in the American Judicial System it's
just curious and the best that they
could offer me was a book on
islamophobia again implying that I was
wrong for even seeking that out they had
all kinds of other flowery books that
talked about wonderful peaceful
coexistence maybe they I was in the
mythology section
but this is what I found this is what I
found in the Christian book section
laying down the sword why we can't
ignore the Bible's violent verses so
there was nothing there was
nothing that spoke to the consequence of
the imposition of sharia as we've seen
this now for over thousand years but
they had no shortage and I don't want to
overstate the case but the fact of the
matter is what they did have was a
specific attack on Christianity and of
course in picking this book up and I was
compelled to do so this is of course
naturally outlining predominantly the
Old Testament not even speaking to the
New Testament and why does that matter
because when Muslims try and say Hey you
folks you're radicals when you quote
from the Quran because there's so much
more to it or you're being selective
friends
we know that the Old Testament in so
many ways was God giving us the laws
which was the precursor to give us the
new testament which in so many ways was
going to provide us the god of laws this
is a sequential process for believers
and yet Muslims are offended when you
mention that there's violence in the
Quran because they want to point to a
part that's less violent and they don't
talk of course about the fact that there
was a time when Muhammad spent as
a man of Peace in Mecca
and the transition to a man of politics
and War in Medina they don't talk about
the fact that as we move deeper into the
Quran the tones changed the violence
changed they don't talk about the fact
that for example only 14% of this book
actually talks about Islam oh pardon me
that only 14% of this book is the the
tenants the founding tenants of Islam
64% of this book is focused on what to
do to unbelievers to cuffer to k a f i r
which in the west we've managed to
sugarcoat and just say well that that's
somebody that's not a Believer but in
fact this is a terrible terrible name a
terrible terrible suggestion because the
true translation is somebody that's a
concealer of Islam and of course that
opens up a whole host of things that you
can do to
them and it's perfectly legitimate
friends we're going to have more of a
conversation about that with our expert
panel I know that Mr Spencer would
probably give the statistics on what's
happened even just in the last 24 hours
how many people have been killed in how
many parts of the country in the world I
want to point you at another book if you
don't know it if you're not familiar
with it it's Sharia law for non-muslims
from the center of the study of
political Islam their website is
political islam.com I recommend it to
you as you are building your own
bookcase so that you can look to the
root of some of this I'm going to tie
this up with a reference to a book by
David Barton called wall Builders and
I'm I'm going to talk now for a little
bit about why this is important wall
Builders and more importantly this book
original intent and it's part of the
wallbuilders series and you can go to
wallbuilders.com to learn more David
Barton has been on a mission to try and
reveal some of the truth of the origins
of this
country why is the truth of our origin
so important because as we talk about
reconciling different political systems
today we have to be honest a about who
we are and B about where we come from
because only if we're dealing squarely
with those terms can we have any
reasonable sense of understanding where
we're going to go but we've seen the
left and you've heard me say this before
in fact that CPAC consistently trying to
manipulate the terms of the argument and
to refresh it so even today as this
justice department seeks to selectively
prosecute or selectively
enforce the efforts or the issues that
are important to
satisfy a special interest agenda that
pumps tens of Millions dollar into
campaign
coffers we see them even just recently
in a case in Chicago go after the
Attorney General decided to school sue
the public school system because a
school teacher had petitioned and wanted
to be able to take 3 weeks off to do a
hodge and of course this would have been
unpaid leave but the idea that the
justice department isn't securing our
borders the justice department isn't in
fact enforcing laws that would have
pertained to the preservation of
marriage the justice department is not
concerned with protecting any of the
laws already on the books visa laws as
they related I have a friend here that
works in the nuclear industry laws that
related to yucka Mountain that might
have helped our energy Independence or
even the Proviso of private sector
business being saign that the government
didn't need to come in and kill EXL the
way they did instead of that we're
seeing selective
enforcement in an effort to undermine or
grind down some of the Christian
institutions and po entally bolster and
pave away for what increasingly is more
Sharia
compliant legislation policy fiscal
policy Sharia finance and I'm going to
turn it over to the rest of our speakers
to give us the introduction and the the
the full explanation of what all of
those things are so family I want to say
thank you so much for having me and for
allowing me to join you this morning and
I hope that I got you all fired up and
ready to get into this fight and to
listen to the rest of our speakers thank
you so much for having me
[Applause]
there's a certain kind of cognitive
dissonance in the uh conference this
weekend because CPAC will tell you that
there's nothing wrong with Sharia and
nobody should be worried about it and
then we have this panel here
and so which is it and how are we going
to know whether this is a real concern
or not I have here the paper panel I
held up earlier that was given out at
the suale con event earlier and of
course I don't know what I'm talking
about so don't listen to me listen to
the paper the paper says that there is
that the F Council of North America
which is the foremost Islamic legal body
in the United States made a ruling in
September 2011 that there is no inherent
conflict between the normative values of
Islam and the US Constitution and the
Bill of
Rights now it also says while clearly
some Muslims do view Sharia as a
hegemonic political force the vast
majority of Muslims especially those
living in the West View Sharia no
differently from the way Jews view ET
Etc you get the idea that it's just this
perfectly reasonable benign things just
like Jewish law just like Catholic canon
law whatever and so this is the
essentially the position of C
except that we were able to sneak in
and I wanted to call your attention to
that statement clearly some Muslims do
view Sharia as a hegemonic political
force but that's obviously a tiny
minority of extremists who are
misunderstanding Islam the first
misunderstand of Islam was Muhammad the
prophet who said Islam must Dominate and
not be dominated Islam must Dominate and
not be dominated and he established in
Medina
the first Islamic political system in
which the unbelievers lived in a state
of subservience he first made an
agreement with them and then violated
the agreements in various ways massacred
exiled the Jewish communities in the
area and instituted a system whereby as
mandated in the Quran non-muslims would
feel themselves
subdued now in Islamic
law that is a absolutely fundamental
aspect of the muslim's relation with
non-muslims that the non-muslim is not
equal to the Muslim because the
non-muslim is a renegade who's rejected
the true Prophet rejected the true faith
and has to be made to suffer in this
world as well as in the next to remind
him always of how he has evily gone to
war against God and it's the muslim's
responsibility to make
sure that though non-muslims are
subjugated and are subservient
in in other words that Allah's
punishment because of their rejection of
him is being carried out that's a
fundamental Cardinal aspect of sharia
now suel Khan would say that's not
Sharia at all that's just a
misunderstanding of sharia purveyed by
people who don't know what they're
talking about so let's look at the
record there have been plenty of sharia
states there were the Great Islamic
empires of the Middle Ages there were
the caliphates there were the sultanates
there are today Saudi Arabia and Iran
Sudan some some areas of
Somalia where Sharia is in
place now when we look at those records
when we look at the historical record of
those Sharia states of the past and we
look at the present human rights record
of Saudi Arabia and Iran do we find that
there is no inherent conflict between
the normative values of Islam and the US
Constitution and the Bill of Rights do
we find that the majority of Muslims do
not view Sharia any differently from how
Jews View Jewish
law don't listen to me look at the
record in every Sharia state that has
ever existed on this planet from the
beginning of Islam until now there have
been restrictions on the freedom of
conscience restrictions on the freedom
of speech absolutely institutionalized
denial of the equality of Rights of
women denial of the equality of Rights
of non-muslims so that they feel
themselves
subdued in accordance with the Mandate
of God of Allah
law and that has always been Sharia and
so now we have at CPAC at the
conservative political action conference
not just in Mother Jones and they're
here today hi guy uh but in in in in in
a place you would think would have some
sense you have people saying that Sharia
is something that it has never
been and is not now
and does not exist in any Islamic legal
book anywhere in the world and yet
people will tell you on in the media oh
Sharia is nothing like that Sharia is
perfectly benign and in the it's
compatible with the Constitution and we
have this in the Washington Post in the
New York Times and at the conservative
political action
conference now the reality is that we
can see obviously what Sharia is you
don't have to listen to me just look at
where Sharia has always been
look at what the Islamic legal manuals
actually say about Sharia read the
Reliance of the traveler read minhaj a
Muslim and look at what they
say what we have now is a concerted
effort to assert elements of sharia in
the workplace in schools everywhere in
America and to assert the principle that
where Islamic law and American law
conflict it is American law that has to
give way and what's the op shot of that
that Muslims get special privileges to
which non-muslims are not privy like the
whole assembly line the whole Factory
thing has to stop so that the Muslims
can pray and then the the meat packing
plants the JB Swift meat packing plants
in Nebraska and Colorado Muslims get
special break times that the non-muslims
don't have and people say well this is
human rights and equal treatment well
actually also coincidentally it
establishes Muslims with rights and
privileges that the non-muslims don't
have the non-muslims are
subdued and the Muslims re Supreme isn't
that aun F coincidence anyway Robert
Muse is a lawyer with the newly
established American Freedom Law Center
which is a very important strike back at
the Sharia initiative in the United
States because it is the First Law
Center in the first place that is headed
by a Jew and a Christian so two of the
foremost lawyers in the Country David
Yami and Robert Muse and it is so
important and so crucial that Jews and
Christians come together as fellow
communities who would be subjugated
under Islamic law and fight back for
freedom and secondly because Yami and
news have been absolutely at the
Forefront of some of the most important
legal cases that involve the assertion
of principles of sharia in the United
States so it gives me a great pleasure
to bring you Robert Muse who will tell
you more about
[Applause]
what thank you for that kind
introduction as he as he indicated I'm a
co-founder of American Freedom law m PA
David Yami he's an orthodox Jew I'm an
orthodox Catholic so we describe
ourselves as the nation's first
authentic judeo-christian law
Fir and a little bit about my background
I was active duty in the Marine Corps
for 13
years here I was an infantry officer in
the the first Persian Gulf War my uh my
dad raised me right he was a Marine in
the Korean War and my two other brothers
were Mar as well and you know when I
started this constitutional law for the
last 12 years uh David Yami and I have
been working together for four years on
very important cases and this past
January we decided to launch the
American Freedom Law Center you know
when I took an oath as an officer in the
Marine Corps I took an oath to support
and defend the Constitution of the
United States against all enemies forign
and
domestic and I slowly start to realize
that some of the worst enemies we have
are domestic enemies domestic enemies to
our Constitution and those battles were
being part in the court I never in my
life had a desire to be a lawyer could
St Wars I was an energy officer I was a
trigger and I saw what was going on I
said I I came home one day I told my
wife I'm leaving the Marine Corps I want
to get a l degree I'm going to go fight
this change my uniform and go fight for
the Constitution and that's what I've
been doing for the last 12 years and
I've been
blessed this is very personal and
important to me as well because my my
wife and I we've been blessed with 12
children
[Applause]
as I say they're they're all boys except
for
10 first nine were girls number 10 was a
boy every after the nine girls everybody
just having children to have a boy right
yeah have nine kids and I want to have a
boy number 10 was a boy and then when
number 11 came was a girl in number 12
they stopped asking me questions and
they realized that U I'm an orthodox
Catholic the mot in my home is blessed
are you among women
so what am I talk about I I've got a
PowerPoint because some of the things I
I have to uh I mean you have to see some
of these pictures you have I've got a a
4minute video that I'm going to I'm
going to show you you have to see what's
going on you know people can talk about
there's there's none of this pricious
influence of Islam or Sharia and it's
it's not really affecting our
fundamental rights I'm going to show you
some empirical evidence of how our
fundamental rights are being eroded and
my the topic I'm going to talk about
civilization Jihad in the First
Amendment because that's what I think
we're under we're under civilization
Jihad whether directly or indirectly and
this from I think president Raiden sums
it up quite a bit you know our our
freedom is never more than a generation
away from Extinction and we have to
continue to fight for those freedoms we
can't just rest on our laes rest on the
our past we have to fight for these
freedoms for our generation and for the
Next Generation we don't want to be the
generation where those freedoms became
extinct and as a father of 12 I tell you
I'm I'm fighting this fight every single
day to ensure that those freedoms are
there for my children and I want them
there for your children as well cuz this
is a great nation despite what some
people will tell you it is an
exceptional Nation it's a nation founded
on judeo-christian principles and that's
what I'm fighting for and here are some
of the cases I just want to run through
L acts 17 vers city of debor some of you
may have seen this
case this was a in Paul there was these
Christian missionaries in 2010 they went
to the Arab Festival in the city of
Dearborn Michigan about 40 miles from
where I live I live in Michigan in in an
Michigan area the city of deborn happens
to be one of the cities with the largest
Muslim population these four Christian
missionaries went peacefully to the Arab
Festival to preach the gospel to the
Muslims just to give you a background of
who these who these four Christian
missionaries were Nabil kesi who has his
medical degree David wood who's a
professor of philosophy at forom
University Paul res kala who at 19 years
old is a junior at NYU and a in nin
mayel who was a young college student
down in Texas nin mayel in N KES are
converts from Islam to Christianity they
will tell you emphatically the most
important decision they ever made in
their life was to become a Christian and
they wanted to share that good news with
other Muslims so they went to the Arab
vessel to do so peacefully well they
went in
peace and they left in handcuffs
literally they spent a night in jail for
allegedly preaching the
peace fortunately for these young for
these uh Christian missionaries they had
video cameras with them and they
captured every minute
[Music]
it's 4 minutes long but it's worth
watching in the red shirt I no problem I
I have no problem
with why you trying to make I'm when we
when we when we made the video last year
when when we made the video last year we
made it explicitly clear that it was the
security we had an issue with not
everyone at the festival security then
we put up a video afterwards saying we
want to make this perfectly clear clear
we don't have any issue with the people
there we have no issue with the people
at Boots we only have issue with people
at security so I I got no issue with you
guys you didn't say in video saying
Islam people as Community
are my mom is Muslim my dad is Muslim my
sister's Muslim all my cousins are
Muslim I love Muslim I got no problem
with the Muslim
Community security
guard you came here looking for trouble
with the w why you start making all
these videos that's a good question we
came here yesterday or last year and we
saw a pamphlet that we had a question
about so we went to the booth who gave
us the pamphlet and we said hey can we
ask you a question about this and they
they said they said yeah they said they
said
yeah I I didn't see
you I just happened to be here last year
my we want to see if it's going better
this year we want to see if it's better
this year than it was last year are you
sure about that I'm pretty sure it's all
the way I think you're looking for more
trouble where not looking for trouble we
want to see things are better and
generally things have been better
security hasn't been hitting US security
hasn't been assaulting us so things are
better I'm glad about that and we are
talking right now and no one's stopping
us from talking so I'm glad about these
things this is the very reason I'm here
to make sure you and I can talk so you
here to preach I would like to preach we
haven't even gotten to that point meach
you I would love to preach you why is
Christianity better than Islam because
Jesus Christ did not claim to be just a
prophet he said he was here to receive
worship he did receive worship he
forgave people's sins he he miraculously
healed people he died on the cross and
rose from the dead these troths have
changed my life have absolutely changed
my life and and I find it so important
to let people know about these things
that I will tell anyone and everyone who
listen so I'm glad you asked the
[Music]
question Who who okay I got a bunch of
you guys who asking questions start like
four of these guys I want I want a man a
humanus deed God what when was Jesus
decided as a God that's an excellent
question 325 years after the Roman Cil
declared him as God people are
worshiping Jesus as God less than a
decade after his death that's not how
could Jesus be a God if he came like any
of us came out out of a woman he came
like any other man comes out of a woman
yeah so in the Old Testament we see a
prophecy saying that a child will be
born to you and he will be the Mighty
God so in the Old Testament it actually
says the Mighty God will be born as a
child to you and and actuality it can't
just be like a half God it actually says
the Everlasting father abiad will be
born to you so this is this is a
prophecy we knew what happened how does
God die you said after his death he was
be God that's an excellent question what
we find in the New Testament is that in
order in order for for God to take our
sins away from us he can't just wave
them away uh if God were just to wave
away sins he wouldn't be a just God so
he takes our sins upon himself he says
all right I can't just wave these sins
away that wouldn't make me a just God
I'm going to pay those sins for you
that's how much he loves us and so he
comes into the world as a man and he
takes our sins for us he does it all
voluntarily he doesn't have to do any of
this have you met Jesus yourself say
again he are great questions guys I'm
loving this anyone else have a question
yeah uh where where in the Bible says
can you find the Bible where says uh
when Jesus says I am God worship me well
in the Bible when people $0000 in any
Bible there's 80 of them if you find
me80 but there's only one let
[Music]
me are you
leg
[Music]
okay being handed right now taken to
jail those police private those the
police Airborne City police officers
they spent the night in jail that was
the video I showed to the jury during
the closing argument their criminal
trial and what I said to them and I say
to you did what you just watch there
happen on a city street in the United
States of
America and the answer is yes these guys
were charged for breach of the peace for
that and just by the way the microphone
that he had wasn't amplifying sound it
was just a pick up the sound for the
camera so this was a street
conversation they were arrested and they
were put in jail jail we had a weeklong
jury trial and thankfully the jury made
up of uh citizens of Dearborn acquitted
them David Yami and I filed a 96 page
civil rights lawsuit against the city of
deborn the mayor the chief of police 17
police officers and two
[Applause]
Festival the city moved to dismiss the
lawsuit and just last week our federal
judge we got a really good federal judge
denied one of their motions and the case
is going to proceed
yeah this stuff can't happen on the city
streets of the United States next case I
want to talk to you about Johny Jesse
Nea who actually happens to be in the uh
in the audience today you surprised me
when I saw him sting out
there this one this case really bothered
me gunto was a uh a retired Marine 20
years in the Marine
Corp two combat tours in
Vietnam he uh when he retired from the
Marine from the Marine Corp he went and
became a civilian employee aboard Marine
Corp base campu North Carolina place
where I was station twice and uh his
youngest son was a sailor ofo the USS
coal and he didn't make it out his son
was one of the one of the sailors that
was killed in that ter
attack so he had a grieving father who
not only changed his North Carolina
license plate officially so it says USS
cold he made his vehicle literally a
monument to a morning father he died
they
rejoiced remember the coold No Quarter
for Islamic
terrorists he had those Vehicles those
decals on his vehicle that he brought
aboard base where he worked where he was
permitted to go as a retired Marine
because you have the benefit to go to
the the commissary The Exchange and you
know use the medical facilities and so
forth obviously he has a dad who was
very much affected by his lamic
terrorist and a complaint had gone up to
the base and the base commander told him
you had an option you had to scrape off
all those decals you had the gold star
there as well for a grieving parent of
losing somebody in in combat scrape off
those decals or scrape off your base
decal that allows you to take that
vehicle on board he said sir I'm not
going to remove those decals
[Applause]
he even went so far as the is an order
to him to ban that vehicle from any
government installation which includ
which included Arlington National
Cemetery a marker for his son and North
Naval Base where the co Memorial was so
he contacted us I believe uh Robert
Spencer actually brought the the case to
me and we uh sued the base in Federal
Court North Carolina and the judge ruled
in our favor and he struck down the
restriction
unconstitutional and they got as soon as
I called I tell you that was one of my
happiest calls when I called him and I
could tell that he was choked up on the
other side I said you get that vehicle
go right back on base get your base
decal and so he did and there he is
standing outside of the
[Applause]
camp amazing I mean we're we're fighting
terrorists Wars and here it is a Marine
Corps Base Camp it was just absolutely
remarkable
afdi American Freedom Defense Initiative
Pam gella is one of my uh one of my
favorite clients we've got represen all
over the
place I didn't put the slide up here for
this one but you you may or may not know
she was uh recently sued by a uh by a
Muslim for her blogging on the Ripka
Berry case she was sued a $10 million
defamation lawsuit against her filed in
Ohio uh for comment she put on a Blog
covering the rifa Barry cases the the
one who sued her was the attorney who
was representing r
David shami and I represented her in
that lawsuit as well and we got it
[Applause]
dismissed this Bell is real it's not
made up it's not you know mysterious or
something that's just theoretical it's
happened here afdi versus smart smart is
the acronym for the uh the the bus comp
the the government organization stands
for a Suburban Mobility Authority for
regional transportation out of uh
Detroit Pam wanted to run this
advertisement on the uh on the buses in
Detroit it's a public forum they take uh
advertisements from different political
organizations and they deny it they
wouldn't tell us why they just denied
and said no you're not going to put this
uh put this up I have a suspicion those
buses run through Dearborne and some of
these other communities and they don't
like this political speech this
religious freedom message that that
she's conveying however the bus company
allowed this one don't believe in God
you're not
alone so if the government the
government says it's perfectly fine this
isn't offenseive to anybody that anybody
who's a Christian or anybody who's a
Believer I mean this is just you know
look at the you know Detroit uh Center
for for reason they can put up their
advertisement but none of this uh you
know Pam Geller advertisement well David
Yami and I sued the smart and the
federal judge actually granted our
preliminary injunction in ordered smart
to uh to run the
advertisements they refuse they still
refuse and the cas is on
so we're trying to get this order
actually enforced but we won the first
round I suspect we're going to win the
second round as well afdi versus
MTA and this here's the uh David Pam
wanted to run a uh a anti- Jihad
advertisement in in response to an
advertisement that was run by this Pro
Palestine anti-israel organization who
put up an ad about getting all military
aid out of Israel and blaming you know
the the military the US is involved in
in Israel with all the problems in the
in the Israeli military so Pam said well
I want to run this
advertisement her anti- Jihad
advertisement and what did the uh the
MTA say that's demeaning speech we don't
allow demeaning speech apparently it's
the meaning to Violent Jihad is to call
them
Savages so they uh so we sued the we
sued the MTA and we just recently filed
a a motion for a preliminary injunction
um and we're going to have hearings on
that coming up shortly and I hopefully
suspect we're going to Prevail in that
casee as
well I could I mean I could go on and on
and on with the number of cases it's
very plain when I see somebody who wants
to who wants to say something truthful
but critical of Islam or somebody who
wants to preach the gospel to Muslims
there is a double standard in a way that
our constitutional rights are being
eroded dramatically eroded I didn't make
up that video of those Christians being
arrested you have you can't even why I
tell people that story like that
couldn't have happened you saw the video
it happened that's all they did is what
you saw in that video and they had to go
through a week- long criminal
trial if we don't fight for these
freedoms we're going to lose them it's
as simple as that and it's very
important what what Pam's doing what
Robert's doing you know it's from my
perspective I you know I'm a lawyer and
I and I love doing these cases I love to
be in the fight for them but if isn't
for people like Pam and Robert who are
willing to speak we wouldn't have these
cases to begin
with and we know that when you do speak
you're going to get hit with these
defamation
that's why David and I started the
American Freedom Law Center we we're
nonprofit We don't charge our clients
for uh for the cases and we wanted we
want to defend not only defend against
those those bogus defamation claims but
also go on the offensive and take it to
them we challenge the AIG Bill probably
most of you people here don't realize
that you're the owner of AIG we have
somewhere a 92% shareholders is the
taxpayers we've given over 80 billion to
AIG who well by the way happens to be
the the uh the world leader in Sharia
compant financing which has to comply
with Sharia where some of the profits on
that goes off to Zak which is the
religious tax that goes to fund um
pro-islamic organizations jihadist
organizations we went about we showed in
the in the litigation that at least 153
million in fact we had a billion but the
judge would at least credit us that $153
million of taxpayer money was going to
these Sharia compliant businesses
supporting those activities in which you
have to have this this special Sharia
Advisory Board to advise on theological
propositions in fact it's very
interesting when we asked the Department
of Justice who was defending AIG this
the IG bailout about the the questions
about Sharia and Sharia comp comping
financing and all the activities they
said oh we can't answer those those are
asking to put theological proposition so
they admitted in their in their request
for admissions that this was a
theological proposition that your
taxpayer money was going to f the judge
the first round ruled in our favor and
then for some reason we still can't
figure it out but R appeal he ruled
against us to some judgment motion but
what he had said the two reasons was
number one he said there's no indication
that the Sharia compant financing
involves any PR TI which we had plenty
of evidence to show that which was not
rebutted by the government and number
two he said well you figure $80 billion
and only $153 million went to that
that's rather the minimist so we don't
see that as a constitutional violation
this is what our federal judge said I'm
going to be arguing that case before the
US code of appeals for six circuit on
April
20th if we don't practice these freedoms
we're going to lose them if we don't
fight for those freedoms we're going to
lose them we have to protect those
freedoms thank you for being
here thank you so much Robert uh donate
your dollars wisely uh American law
Freedom Center is represented me pro
bono we're talking uh3 to $400,000 to
spend off that $10 million lawsuit
donate to them also donate to S and afdi
because I do run those ads and they cost
and in Manhattan after I ran the ground
zero mards I used to buy the minimum
number of buses like five buses so of
course now if I want to buy a bus it's a
minimum buy of 58k to buy the size of
buses this is what they do and I'm going
to tell you right now we got another
want you coming you don't know this
brother but you know they for Sharia
going up in Kansas City Sharia got
questions get answers you see that ad
that I ran that was their ad uh come to
Islam got questions get answer I just
ran exactly what they did but I flipped
it so my ads are now in
consideration Sharia got questions get
answers so mine says Sharia got fwa get
answers call 1 1800 I live free okay and
get off the phone
[Applause]
true
storry again the Sharia is you have to
understand the blasphemy laws under the
Sharia do not insult Islam do not offend
Islam do not criticize Islam these are
the laws under the Sharia the blasphemy
laws and that's what you're witnessing
with these ads that that are rejected
with a self enforcing Sharia in the in
media the media who will not speak
critically of Islam this is Sharia So
when you say there's no Sharia hello
you've become ignored to it it's like a
drip drip drip it's happening to you as
we speak and the reason why I'm so
thrilled that our keynote speaker is
here Jay Christian Adams of the
Department of the former Department of
Justice is because Muslim Brotherhood
organizations in this country are using
the Department of Justice as their legal
arm you see Ario Pantano mentioned the
school where the doj so suit and the
school lost had to pay $75,000
and legal fees they sued a county in New
Jersey because the correction officer
wanted to wear the nikab and they're
like you know you got to you got to wear
their uniform the Department of Justice
sued and one Disney is being sued
because she wants to wear the hijab now
Disney said look we're going to put you
in the back because we have a an image
you know Disney Snow away s you know
they want to put Snow White in the burka
um and they're suing
they're suing Disney's had a dress code
since
1957 I will could be more American than
Disney Cashers at Walmart and Target who
will not handle meat that's not H sued
and they won so this is imposing again
Islam on the secular market place and I
think it's very important that you
understand how the doj has been
compromised and uh J Christian Adams I
just want to say is one of America's
great unsung heroes depending upon who
writes the history books this man is
peerless he is singular I met J
Christian Adams when I received the anti
tale award for courage from the David
Howard's Freedom Center we were
co-winners
um
and what you need to understand is he
was a lawyer senior lawyer senior pay
grade all the perks you know what
working for the government is we used to
raise our children be a doctor now it's
like go to the government you know
that's where that's where the money's at
and he what he saw he could not fathom
what he saw he could not sanction and he
left and he blew the whistle on the
Black Panther Party I'm sure you know
that story were
[Applause]
many menacing menacing the voters with
billy clubs and what this is all about
is disarming the public you are being
disarmed in this war you need to
understand understand why all of this is
happening and I would like to bring uh J
Christian Adams up here uh and I cannot
tell you how thrilled I am because just
so that you know I mean he's scheduled
to be with Ed me as we speak why that
scheduling conflict I don't know it is
CPAC after all um but he's here he's
here to speak with us and I am
enormously enormously
[Applause]
grateful I think I've stepped into a
rally you should have seen the one I
left it was quite like this uh but
indeed I I was I apologize for being
late I was moderating a panel with uh
the former Attorney General of the
United States uh an incredible uh uh
Great American that that uh truly was
I'm sorry you couldn't be there but
that's how this worked out today um it
was interesting watching that video that
I we all just saw did you pick up the
little Clues uh the the sort of uh uh
gentle advertisement of thuggery when he
says you just here to start trouble of
course no one is ever there to start
trouble but that's how thugs talk uh
that's how thugs talk and unfortunately
if there's two things that I'm most
interested in talking about these days
it's this growing Thug movement uh that
is sort of taking over portions of the
law where uh force or power makes right
and not principle and and so that that's
one of the things but it was interesting
the topic was shredding the Constitution
and this great American Ed me was asked
as the topic of the p i moderated uh it
what's going on how is Obama shredding
the Constitution and I I was stunned to
hear him talk about the justice
department I thought that was my gig you
know what are you doing taking my all my
all my great lines uh but he talked
about the New Black Panther case uh he
talked about the justice department
being unwilling to bring cases to get
dead people off the voter roles and so
there is something a miss and I think
most Americans recognize this but as as
Pam said I was at the justice department
uh for 5 years uh I was in the voting
section and I enforced uh I enforced
federal election laws and I brought the
case against Malik Zulu shabaz King
Samir shabaz uh who's the other guy
Jerry Jackson and the New Black Panther
Party uh that case I'm sure you've all
seen the video by now um where they were
standing in front of a polling place in
Philadelphia on the day that President
Obama was elected what you might not
have seen and I would always encourage
you to see by purchasing a copy of my
buling Justice uh is the photo of
president or then Senator Obama uh
marching with M Zulu shabaz in s Alabama
in
2007 in March uh he appeared that day
with Malik Zulu shabaz at the same
Podium and a fellow at the podium was
named Naji Muhammad Naji Muhammad is the
Minister of War of the New Black Panther
Party uh and he's based in Atlanta and
you Google the words Training Day New
Black Panther Party you can watch a
video of this man who stood at the
podium uh calling for the murder of the
Cab County police officers uh with
AK-47s as you lie in weight with ski
masks over your face uh yes indeed this
was all a jubilee weekend which is a
celebration of the Voting Rights march
from s of Montgomery okay so I was at
the justice department what I'm going to
do is talk about some of the things I
saw there most of these were in my book
so if you read the book and already
bought it you can leave the room now uh
but otherwise uh let me go through it
um somebody already mentioned the
Berkeley School District case let me
tell you a little more details about
that Berkeley School District uh was an
Illinois uh School District where a math
teacher by the name of and I always mess
these up there's nobody like Robert
Spencer to get the names right or Frank
GFF I don't because this is not my area
of expertise I am I'm a I'm an election
lawyer uh saf f con I think safura con
uh she was a math teacher at Berkeley
school district and she asked off I do
this all the time she asked off for it
wasn't three weeks by the way uh it was
actually 19 days which translated almost
four weeks of time uh she asked off uh
during the final days of the semester
when math tests were being given and
Grading needed to be done so it wasn't
just you know in September or August but
it was actually in the worst possible
time she could have asked and so she
asked off and the school district said
are you crazy this is this is finals you
need to give the test you need to grade
the test and get the grades in so uh she
did not like the answer that she
received and so she quit she quit her
job as a
teacher uh in any other sane
Administration and I include the Clinton
Administration among that I'm a big fan
of saying I wish Bill Clinton were the
president right now because it would be
an improvement
okay and that's the
truth uh in a sane Administration that
would have been the end of saur Khan's
plight but in this Administration
everything is different in this
Administration under the leadership of
ass Assistant Attorney General Tom Perez
a true radical's
radical uh they brought a lawsuit called
United States versus Berkeley School
District you were tax dollars at
work and they alleged that this uh
denial of her right to go into
pilgrimage to Mecca was a violation of
her rights as uh a free exercise of
religion under the Civil Right okay 19
days like so many defendants who have
not read my book in Justice they caved
okay they thought oh my gosh the justice
department is bringing the case it must
be a good case it must be a
straightforward down the middle of the
road easy to win case they don't
understand it's exactly the opposite now
this justice department is pushing the
Frontiers on the weaker cases they're
bringing the weaker cases and states are
picking up on it I'm working as hard as
I can to alert States like Arizona South
Carolina
just South Carolina just filed an action
against Eric Holder to get the voter ID
approved uh States everywhere are
figuring it out Florida did the same
thing uh Mississippi is going to go to
court on their voter IDE
they real the Justice Department
officials maybe they don't realize but
but uh their gig is up and and it's it's
it's finally gotten through okay so they
they they bring this case what does
Michael mcy say about this case how rare
is it to have a former Attorney General
oine about the actions of a successor
here's what Michael mcy says about the
Berkeley School District case quote it
exhibited various uh very dubious legal
judgment it was a real legal reach okay
19 days was unprecedented and you know
you you will have every leftwing blog
talk about how uh this was just
religious liberty but it was
unprecedented the most before that was
three or 4 days of accommodation the
most before that that a court upheld was
three or 4 days and this was a 19-day
request um I wrote here's what Tom Perez
says about this about the case it was a
profoundly personal request by a person
of Faith okay that's how he
characterized the 19-day request to go
to Mecca and as I write about in my book
a devout Catholic who is now at the
justice department should take a copy of
the complaint and ask for 19 days
off to go to the Stations of the Cross
in Poland uh and then go to Rome for
Good Friday and for Easter and and as I
say in the book
um uh some religions are more equal than
others obviously because everybody knows
what would happen to that request let me
move backwards though in time to another
story uh and this one's an interesting
one uh it also all these involve of
course the justice department uh and
again this is not my area of expertise
as much but I'll tell you a story uh the
Islamic Society of North America has a
conference um and in 2007 or 2008 an
email went around uh asking for justice
department volunteers to go to the
conference to work to Mana Booth okay
now this I was Far fied from this but
there's one particular attorney uh who
who was in the voting section and his
name was Joel R right Joel R he was a
marine uh and he WR he wrote an email he
wrote an email he he had reply to all
nothing good comes out of reply to all
we're not that smart so so the email
goes out asking for volunteers to the uh
Islamic Society North American
convention you know on government time
you just go out to Chicago and and man
boo so Joel hits replied all he says
wait a minute folks um isn't this the
unindicted co-conspirator in the Holy
Land Foundation trial down in Dallas is
it a very is it a very good idea for the
justice department to be sending Booth
sponsorship to the the unindicted
co-conspirator in another Justice
Department case so Joel of course was
like swatting at a hornet snacks and I
just sat back and and watch uh but my
point is this is not something new my
point is that this sort of thing has
been going on for good or ill uh I'm
just describing to you that this is
happening and this has been happening
since the prior Administration so uh
let's go back to the current
administration because it's much more
fun on May 19th of this past year on May
19th it was movie day at the justice
department and I've written about this
at PJ media uh it was movie day at the
justice department where an email went
out to everybody drop your work uh drop
your obligations and come on down to the
theater at Main Justice RFK building
where they would be showing a screening
of uh what a billion Muslims really
think and uh this movie I again not my
field of expertise but I am told that
the investigative project on terrorism
has ripped this thing apart on a
statistical
methodology um but the notion to me is
that that's most important at least that
this Administration is now sponsoring
Cinema day on the taxpayer dime where
you can come and watch movies that many
people think are statistically flawed on
their polling data of Muslim communities
that simply didn't happen in a prior
Administration Frank frankly it
shouldn't happen in any Administration I
don't care if it's find out what a
billion Catholics think find out what a
billion Jews think this is not the sort
of thing the taxpayers want to see the
government spending their priorities on
okay now is when it gets really
fun who are they
hiring who is being hired by the Obama
Administration to replace me after I
left uh at the justice department well
PJ media uh again if I'm if I don't Hawk
my book enough I urge you to go to PJ
media where I serve as as a legal editor
uh did something amazing we filed a
Freedom of Information Act request uh on
this justice department asking for the
resumés of all of the attorneys that the
Obama Administration has hired now if
you've read my book you know that they
treat the a Foya the freedom information
act request of uh conservative
organizations much differently than for
example they treat Ryan Riley who said
here with TPM up Breer he just calls up
and they give him the information he's
their friend
so uh when it comes to conservative
media you have to file a lawsuit in
federal court which is what we did
because they wouldn't turn over the
information so we filed a case I think
it was called osc media LLC versus
holder and they eventually turned over
the resumés
of3 new attorneys and you can read the
biographies of every single one of them
which is the name of the
series every single one of them at PJ
media it's 113 biographies that we
researched after we got the resumés we
did background information and lo and
behold wouldn't you believe that every
single one of them came from a leftist
or radical or leftwing or political
background there wasn't a single
conservative there wasn't even a single
moderate among this group now I I'm not
going to go through all of the people
that are on these but I'm going to at
least name two of them
okay the I'm going to name three of them
excuse me the let's talk about the
people who actually brought the Berkeley
School District case I told you about
one was a woman named Barda Hussein who
spent hundreds of hours helping
terrorists sigmo
proon now that's one of the things
there's nothing wrong with doing that
let's get that straight it you're free
if you want to and Andy McCarthy will
say that that says a lot about you but
you're free to go do proon or work for
terrorist but in another generation that
would disqualify you for working at the
justice department and what we have seen
in these resumés is just the opposite
that it appears to be a qualifier a key
to get in the resume the job uh
interview door and there's resume after
resume after resume of attorneys who
spent their time doing pro bono work for
terrorists in
Daniel Freeman is another one he also uh
is in the voting section
now um another attorney on the Berkeley
case is rahima
abim uh and so it's Barda Hussein rahima
abim and here's my favorite one Aaron
Schuman Aaron Schuman is one of the
attorneys of Justice who brought this
case who who was instrumental if you
follow the husana Taber the N nothing
destructive loss by the jce Department
about 4 weeks ago on religious liberty
where the justice department was arguing
that churches can't appoint their own
ministers look into it folks it's scary
not even Justice Kagan agreed with the
justice department it was nine to
nothing okay um Aaron Schuman came to
work on religious Liberties at this
justice department this will tell you
everything you need to know guess where
he came from before he came to Justice
he worked for the Americans United for
separation church and state which if you
know is one of the most militantly
atheist and anti-catholic organizations
in the country it's formed in 1946 as an
anti-catholic organization he's now in
charge of protecting religious liberty
at the doj so it tells you the sort of
the
priorities um
now another attorney is and I'll tell
you just one more who worked uh for GMO
Anila and I can't pronounce this gizia
gz
IFA okay
uh this one really tops the charts she's
now in the Civil Rights division the
justice department she advocated for the
release of a GMO detainee named Omar
Kadar Carter Kate Carter Carter Carter
okay Omar Cotter uh who was charged uh
who was charged with murder uh of
multiple people uh in the Middle East
and I suspect you know far more about
this than me by the look on your face
probably if it's Omar cter it's one and
it was a US medic and he was technically
a Canadian if it's in Afghanistan uh
well uh Omar cter was charged with the
murder of us medic and this now justice
department attorney was his chief
Advocate uh while she was at the uh well
she was at the Children's Law Center
it's a strange combination but I I raise
this because you see a pattern again
nobody says you aren't allowed to do
this sort of thing and I certainly
wouldn't people have a right to counsel
but the question I leave you with is why
are so many of them showing up as
attorneys at the arer justice department
I will submit to you that is because
their work is viewed as a badge of honor
and people will tell you it's perfectly
honorable they they won't even mince
words about it um the last thing I want
to mention is the conflicts problem at
doj uh many of the senior political
people the highest level people doj
including Tom Corelli who served as the
associate attorney general is the number
three at Justice probably Eric Holder
but it's not clear um had conflicts when
they came to Justice they were
conflicted out from working on a wide
variety of terrorism cases because they
had been working on the other side okay
Tom pelli is one of them and the
department has been very very tight
fisted about releasing some of this
conflict data and of course uh uh many
in the media and and others are are just
they're dogged and they never let it
drop and that's why you see it all the
time we know exactly how many conflicts
holder and pelli have um Let me let me
just close on this
note
that there was a time and it wasn't very
long ago that the justice department
exemplified the best in America and
there is a wide spread perception that
is not simply held by conservatives not
simply held by
Republicans that this justice department
is representing the worst in America and
that this attorney general is not fit to
hold the
office and and let's just hope that uh
his days in that office are numbered
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
in the
struggle we are
all the
soldiers there is nobody else who is
going to fight these societal battles
for us this is not a military struggle
although obviously the military
dimension of it is is is connected it's
the same fight but when we are fighting
these cultural societal initiatives it
is up to every one of us and our next
speaker exemplifies a free citizen who
has taken it upon himself to fight
against the encroachment of sharia and
to defend the freedom of speech the
freedom of conscience the equality of
Rights of all people before the law
James laery of the Virginia
and I have to add that James has
recently joined the board of our new
international organization a coalition
of anti- jihadists in America and Europe
and elsewhere to stop islamization of
America of Nations stop islamization of
Nations and James is also a board member
of that
sorry thank you uh in the interest of
full disclosure I am an Irish Catholic
Zionist add some balance in this room
I'm a veteran of the US
Navy my wife and I were talking the
other night and I said you know there's
one good thing that all this anti-sharia
stuff has brought to us we' met a lot of
good interesting people and I was
reminded of that today as I sat up here
looking down this table um it's like um
it's like being in really good company
like those nights at monachello when
Thomas Jefferson dying
alone I live in the wahabi carer in
Northern
Virginia it is Route 7 if any of you are
familiar with it um you know my house is
on the p list for the Fairfax County
Police and every uh hour or so they
swing by and if I'm up during the night
I see the search lights go over our
house um my life has been threatened
numerous times as all the people up here
have have
experience I always laugh when I get
invited to these Interfaith
meetings because I'm told well we've got
to get along you know and and as our our
uh our leading candidate for the
Republican nomination says this is a
religion of peace and they tend to treat
Islam as if it's a bunch of unitarians
who are having a bad
day it is not that at all uh the Carl
Ridge Ministry sent a TV crew out to
follow me around at one point and I went
to the infamous Dar Al hedra M which is
I'm within the 3 Mile Zone there my wife
and I often wonder why we get heada a
lot we're in the the three M zone of Dar
hedra where all of the terrorists attack
cowards uh attended and we're part of
the congregation there and I took this
film crew with me and we pull up and
there's a madrasa at this MOS and all
the kids were out in the yard and we
pulled out and they had a van so they
rolled the door back and they were
shooting film and all the kids in the
playground ran over to the fence and
guess what they
yelled FBI
now what schoolyard in America can you
go where kids even know what the FBI is
these kids saw it um part of what I do
is is the front line sort of stuff many
of you here I see a lot of familiar
faces of people who stood in the rain
with me at uh David Ramadan speeches
where Ed M was there to endorse him
let's not forget that
um I've been uh a protest at darl hedra
a protest in Arlington where the
Arlington Police hassled us we've all
been in these and I see many faces here
today who participated in those we need
to do more of that it's cool to know
what the Muslim Brotherhood is it is
important that you read Robert's books
and that you understand that but it is
equally important that you on what you
know this week I lobed for an
anti-sharia bill in
Virginia I lobbed against the Virginia
Chamber of
Commerce the Virginia Bar
Association I mean not I don't think
there there are there are some terrific
lawyers in this room no doubt about it
but um I don't none of them were there
with the bar association and then the
Muslim Society of
Virginia and the Adams mosque in
Northern Virginia which is sort of the
propaganda center of the Jihad up here
um they lobbied against us um I was I
was pretty much it the first day I was
the witness I was the only one there to
talk against it um other groups the Tea
Party AC America a number of other GR
groups got involved but we're on the
losing side in Virginia right now we are
outnumbered and we're outnumbered not
just by the people that we can recognize
as the enemy we're outnumbered by
Republicans who work with
them yeah the governor somebody
mentioned uh Virginia everyone thinks
Virginia is a very conservative State I
if this is a conservative State I'd hate
to see what Massachusetts is like
because we are are being outgun by them
literally and
figuratively and they are they have are
good lobbyists they are
organized and we're just basically
missing it missing the boat so if you
don't remember anything else I say today
remember that I'm asking that act on
what you know uh start an organization
in your state a state organization s
know the ground they know the people and
they're best suited to fight this and
this is a fight the fight doesn't stop
until we stop fighting but we've got to
start the fight here sometime
soon and I get the feeling for a lot of
people that they think that they've met
their
responsibility when they read one of
Robert's books and they think well I've
done my bit well you're not there are
people good people in PS through out
America again
deerb uh where people have to to carry
guns to
survive uh it is
serious and what I guess I'm asking you
today is please give this your prayerful
thought and look at it one story um my
wife and I my wife is sitting right here
[Applause]
we joke that among the many good things
that President Reagan did for America
was introduce us we were married in
'99 uh I got that you're right
right uh we we uh we live in in the
community there where it is just they're
really I it's just so bad and I'd invite
any of you who want to go on the terror
tour of Northern Virginia
I can show you the Starbucks where they
sat and sketched out the Pentagon on the
napkin according to the FBI agents who
do the investigation I can show you two
houses that were put up as bond for the
blind
shape uh it is it's a center and it's
Northern Virginia it's a town sounds
like a Jimmy Stewart sort of town it's
called Bailey's Crossroads and and it is
it is where where they laid out the
whole thing
um my wife and I saw in the paper one
night that the Islamic study Academy
which is a school operated by the Saudi
government uh that is teaches Sharia and
operates on Sharia um was was renewing
their lease the County government leases
them property to do this to teach this
stuff so my wife Andrea and I went and
testified against it and we started out
by asking questions and this made the
Board of Supervisors ious so they
immediately attacked us uh said that we
had one supervisor said we had slandered
Islam under Sharia you slander Islam
it's all over you're dead uh so I got up
there and I said uh you know uh and I'll
tell you who it was at the end was going
to throw you even more um we think that
you should not lease property these
people they hate Christians they hate
Jews they just about hate everybody um
and we don't think you should do it and
he came back at us and he said to me um
you know Mr lafy um I'll bet did you
know that the Army troops at Fort belor
go there for farsy
lessons and I said no I didn't know that
he says I'll bet you object to that and
I said nope those are exactly the people
who ought to be going to the Islamic St
Academy they know what to do with people
who talk about Mur murdering Jews they
know what to do with people who've been
involved in murdering Americans and
attempting to kill the
president the guys at Fort belar know
how to handle that and I'm all for them
going well he just about gave
birth but you know virtue like that goes
rewarding he's a US
Congressman Jerry Connelly from
Virginia Jerry Connelly
Val well the valid dictorian at the
school was the one Abu Ali who who
plotted to kill President Bush and some
members of the Senate and um he um I
he's a really bad character and he went
when they went in he got 30 years for
that I guess you know 30 years for that
and he comes back in and this judge
says Mr Ali you've done terrible things
here and uh and you know you've got this
sentence and uh what do you think and
the guy and Abu says I would do it again
matter of fact I'd kill you and the oh
wait a minute let's look at this
sentence he says I think I see life
sentence here and he changed it the
judge changed it right on the SP
[Applause]
that'll be Obama's end of term
partner but what this gentleman was
saying about the justice department I
went to the um the briefing on the hate
crime Summit and I went there and it was
all Muslim officials
speaking and remember this is a justice
department meeting got up and really
ragged on two groups the FBI and NYPD
so whatever they're doing they're doing
something good and uh in particularly
the New York police intelligence
unit so let me just say this is a this
is a spiritual war that we're fighting
it is not a religious War but it is a
spiritual war uh we are coall by
scripture to be co-workers of the
truth and that's what what my wife and I
and many others within our groups see us
doing standing up standing up at Council
meetings standing up to the government
the government in Fairfax County
Virginia mails out notices for Muslim
dinners for Muslim to recruit Muslims
into the into their classs at government
expense um we we stand up against this
and I would ask you uh just as I had to
do this week where I had to work alone
for a good part of the week um we need
other people we need other bodies we
need people who will courageously stand
up wherever you are whatever state I
guarantee you there's a problem in and
uh talk with us uh I will plug Pam's
book stop islamization of America is the
only book you need right now after
you've read all the good stuff that
these guys do the back get on your way
out after you've read all the good stuff
that these guyses can tell you about the
Muslim Brotherhood and get an idea of
the the underpinnings of the theoretical
underpinnings of jihad in this country
then you need to act P's book tells you
how to do that it tells you how to fight
tells you where to fight gives you some
of the tricks that all of us have
learned during this time and if you take
that and only pick out a chapter of it
and do it in your community that week
you'll do tremendous good for this
country
[Applause]
okay um just in closing I wanted we want
to take questions just understand that
it is enormously important your role in
this no one is going to save you you are
going to save you on September 11th 2001
when Muslim terrorists drove those
planes into those
buildings with those doctors and lawyers
and stock Brokers and Mothers and
Fathers and Sons and Daughters wearing
uniforms were they are
soldiers are they all fighters yeah yeah
they
are yeah you are it is incumbent upon
you you cannot go to this conference and
say they're handling it we're okay let's
go have dinner you cannot do that you
must fight this war you must you will
win this war you know I I files it's a a
Freedom of Information app request with
with Department of Justice because I
gotten wind of uh them using using the
racial Paradigm that they use to create
legislative districts to create Muslim
majority legislative districts so I
asked for the very narrow very narrow
request for the Cor respondence between
them the doj and the groups named as
Muslim Brotherhood operatives in the
laras lar Hamas Jewish Hamas the larest
the lar the largest Hamas funding trial
in our nation's history in Holy Land the
holyland foundation trial in Texas do
you know when they finally got back to
me I was told it was such an enormous
request that there were over 14,000
documents now mind you I don't know how
many pages each document is 14,000
documents between the doj
and Muslim Brotherhood groups like the
Council of America Islamic relations
Islamic Society of North America Islamic
circle of North America so on and so on
and so on now finally I got the first
batch I said okay send me send it to me
in dumps send me the first few hundred
it took a year and a half okay and we
got the first St and I can tell you
what's
extraordinary in the the entire package
is the Casual relationship ship the surv
relationship are we we going to buy
lunch be meeting how much money would
you need $1,000 should cover it I mean
that in itself is not a Smoking Gun but
the entire package is a Smoking Gun of
course my next Freedom of Information
Act request is going to be for the same
document with Jewish groups and
Christian groups and I guarantee you if
I get four I get a
lot so I think we should take some
questions please buy the book stop the
islamization of America IT addresses EX
your community what you're experiencing
we are not against Muslims okay we are
not against Muslims I know anti-muslim
islamophobic bigot not we are we are
counter
Jihad I don't care if you worship a
stone just don't Stone me with it that's
it equal rights for all under the law
thank you so much for coming and sitting
in your
[Applause]
SE okay
we just have a few more minutes so let's
go right to the questions yes' I'm just
curious where are we with the ground
zero oh thank you I just to say you see
there proof thank you welcome I owe
you5 the ground zero m is proof that
what you say matters you had a president
who came out supported it not just
supported it but supported it at the
ifar dinner that was his message at the
ifar dinner you had a mayor
a complicit man who came out by Tom fit
the um Judicial Watch Judicial Watch
filed the Freedom of Information Act
request according to emails between
Bloomberg's office and the grand zero
Musketeers the Bloomberg Administration
was filling out the forms the Bloomberg
Administration was writing the letters
to the Bloomberg Administration on how
to frame it I am saying the media the N
media wanted that mask built they love
that mask NBC name musketeer Sharie alal
the NBC person of the year here's a man
who had a rap sheet here was a man who
defaulted on not one but $200,000 bank
loans he didn't pay his taxes Kan Ed is
looking to evict him he doesn't pay his
rent and he's NBC person of the year
okay but we defeated that mosque you did
that tens of thousands showed up to the
rallies that we held tens of and without
the media our first rally was June 6th
10,000 people showed up even anary M
rallies that were held they got
thousands and on September 11
2010 we had 30 roughly 30,000 people you
did that they fear you they fear you you
have enormous power because the
individual can change the course of
human events if we know anything about
human history we know that never forget
your power I'm one girl with a Blog
don't ever forget that that's
it I want to add one thing about the
mosque also you will hear you may have
already heard
that it's built it's open they're having
events the park 51 Community Center had
a big art exhibition not too long ago
and people started to contact us and say
how do you feel now that the community
center that you opposed is now open well
this is just more media deception
they're still in that Burlington Cod
Factory building that was destroyed on
9/11 or partially destroyed on 911 they
didn't build their 16 story Victory
mosque they're just so they just
declared Victory and got
out and mo may still be built but the
fact that they did
not uh they did not begin work on it on
September 11th 2011 as they had
originally announced is an indication of
the fact that we the people have
power Mr ly called us to action a few
months ago I I live in Houston Texas a
friend of mine and I got together he's
an expert on Sharia I was just learning
Sharia we put together a slideshow
presentation and it's basically uh based
on the book uh Sharia law for
non-muslims I'm glad to be able to use
your book now Panela for some more
information so is this the type of thing
we we actually unfortunately we put out
350 invitations right in our
neighborhood which is a Conservative
Republican neighborhood we have three
attendees okay it's a little
discouraging but we're not discouraged
and so we're planning uh additional uh
seminars on Sharia law for non-muslims
and I would just like to encourage other
people even if you have limited
knowledge get your knowledge and go out
and start having seminars to educate
Americans on Sharia law that's great you
were successful those were three people
those were three people that didn't know
and those three people know three people
and those three people know and know and
that's how it gets started that's how
the ground zero mosque Was Defeated it
was a BL I started blogging on it in
December December
2009 and the media wouldn't touch it as
a matter of fact it was Ved on the front
page of the New York oh look is this not
fabulous look what we're doing in New
York aren we all that in a bag of chips
that's how it was that's how I found mad
about it in a laudatory article in the
New York Times that's very important
that's how you start that's how you
start and you will come under withering
criticism and that means that you're
doing something
right you know something
else just one second I just remembered
that you know you know Pamela mentioned
she first blocked on this in December
2009 and that's when I first heard about
it it was a front page story in the New
York Times and just incidentally to show
you how deeply entrenched the Muslim
Brotherhood groups are in the United
States and how powerful they are and how
close they are to the mainstream media
the that first initial article which I
read on Atlas shrugs out of the New York
Times the New York Times quoted The
Ground Zero MOS Mom F Abdu saying that
the closeness of this building to the
World Trade Center Towers is Iconic and
this will be a mosque that that is in
inextricably connected to Ground Zero
these are not his exact words but this
was the import and if you go and that
was that was right there in the paper
and on the online edition and that's
where she got it but if you go to the
archival copy of that story in the New
York Times archives today that sentence
is not in there because they started to
push the story after Pamela started
bringing pressure on this they started
to push the the idea that this is not a
mosque and it's not a ground zero it has
nothing to do with ground zero it's just
coincidental the T right over there this
is coincidental that the thing fell
through the roof the The Landing here
for the planes fell through the ceiling
of this building and uh that Muslims
built triumphal mosques on the sites of
jihad victories that has nothing to do
with any of this and so they had to
excise the evidence that this is exactly
how these people had been talking right
before this he actually said that the
the building which was parti destroyed
911 attacks his words were was iconic of
Ground Zero was iconic and that's why it
was such an important such an important
Jam s to hold go that's okay sir I I
think what you're doing is great and
that's that's what most of us should do
um I would look for friendly audiences
and those are Evangelical
churches you know conservative
Evangelical churches that are biblically
based uh conservative Catholic groups
like OB day um and
TRS and and and don't be afraid to
protest don't be you see something wrong
you know see something say If you see
something protest something